i wasn't highly recruited i wanted to go
to maryland and the maryland coach was
like oh you got to work in a jump shot i
started playing in fourth grade i too
was not good i was tripping over lines
on the floor like
what have you thought about finances one
of our owners they owned the stock
exchange so it's like why am i not
talking about stocks and what can i get
into it never occurred to me to do that
because you know you come into league at
22 i'm like i'm gonna buy an apartment
complex
this is the reunion where former college
athletes meet up to discuss lessons
learned about sports money and life
[Music]
well welcome into the reunion i'm taylor
brooks here with angela mccauchy and
nafisa collier well you know before we
really dive into things i want us to
zoom out a bit uh you know so much time
has passed you know you guys being in
the wnba time in college when you look
at this moment right now did you
envision your life being what it is
right now i didn't even growing up um
playing with all the boys they're like
hey you can play in this thing called
the wba one day and i'm like what's that
you know then i started envision playing
in the wba but i never envisioned going
to different countries learning
different languages being an olympian
getting a gold medal right so those are
experiences that you just
i mean people dream of you know so it's
been an amazing ride i think it was the
dream but you don't know what to
envision so you see like the big
milestones like i want to go to the
olympics someday right i want to play
the wnba someday but it's like the
day-to-day like this kind of stuff or
like playing overseas that you really
don't think about i didn't at least in
high school and college really
i mean it's it's so cool to think you
know just how beautiful it is that
basketball you know has given you so
many things and the work that you put
into basketball has given you so many
things so i want to know when you knew
you were better than everyone else
when did y'all know you were right
okay so i started at eight years old
always played just loved it and i was
like the last one coming off the bench i
was like not that player people think
that from our success but i wasn't that
player i feel like during my career i've
always had to be the type to prove
people wrong i wasn't highly recruited i
wanted to go to maryland and the
maryland coach was like oh you got to
work on your jump shot so i've always
had to overcome these obstacles and even
at louisville i'm not going past the
first round of tournament but by my
senior year we're in the national
championship game playing uconn we've
been being ranked so i've always had to
overcome to be a part of a legacy with
louisville it's really really good to
see that because now more girls will go
into different schools and create their
own legacies
yeah i started playing in fourth grade
so kind of around the same time i too
was not good i was super tall lanky i've
always been like tripping over lines on
the floor like
not graceful at all i think i started
noticing that i was getting better
probably around like sixth grade seventh
grade
and then eighth grade for sure you kind
of see the separation a little bit there
i think we should take a little trip
down memory lane i know how crazy how
loud it would get in stores how would
you just describe that fan base at uconn
you know our gym was a little bit
smaller so it only fit 10 000 people so
it felt so loud but our fans are so cool
and like i said some of my best memories
are from there and a lot of it had to do
with the games and the fans so when you
all make it to the wnba and you're
having these conversations about money
making decisions who did you go to i'm
still learning i feel like because you
know it is even though like like you
said like our paychecks aren't a lot
it's still more money i've ever than
i've ever seen so it feels like you have
like so much money when you first start
out yeah so relying on people like my
agent my parents you know the older
people on my team who have been through
this i think you make a few mistakes
before you realize okay this is the
route i need to go i think any
successful business person will tell you
that they've made so many mistakes
before and it's nothing to be ashamed of
it's a learning experience you know you
want to be able to call the people you
know for different things so even with
um to encourage all the players talk to
your owners your owners are big time
successful business people ask them
their story talk to them about what
they're doing i didn't know that in the
beginning yeah you know so that's just a
little word of advice for everyone out
there for someone watching whom he
doesn't understand wnba players going
overseas can you explain that process
for them yes it is a long grind you
talking about eight months in another
country great thing is your family
becomes your teammates it is very tough
you have to be mentally tough my first
year was 2020 i was going to play in
china i was there for 10 days and then
chronovirus hit there first so i had to
come home it took like a half year
playing in france like going into the
wnba season so my body would be ready
and things like that but i could also
enjoy myself that's still a sacrifice
just the fact that you go over there
that's the sacrifice yeah yeah
absolutely yes yeah and you're just
thinking okay well when can i see them
but then in the back of your head you're
also like i'm doing this uh for them
as well
you know before she retires i want them
to have their first million dollar
contracts
they deserve it and i i feel like it is
coming soon i would not be mad about
this
i retweet that so what has your or how
has your definition of a good teammate
evolved as you've gotten older having
good communication being supportive
being encouraging and being a little bit
vulnerable your teammates want to see
you be vulnerable i think as i've gotten
more vulnerable i've gotten close with
my teammates something i do always want
to frame and i want you all's take on
this i think too often when we're
talking to girls young women we frame
being a woman like as an obstacle
something you're having to overcome all
the time and i don't think that that's
the right way to frame it i know we all
gain a lot of strength you know from
being from being women and what ways you
know has just your experience as a woman
made you a stronger better person when
you have to be stern you have to be
confident you have to know what you want
so your nose aren't negotiated so yeah
no is a complete sentence that's what
i'm always still knows of complete
sentence what about for you i think
because
people see it as an obstacle it makes us
tougher being a woman is so so powerful
and we have like this inner strength
because
even if people are doubting us we know
that we can do it exactly yeah
absolutely so as you look forward to the
next 10 years
what do you want to accomplish i
probably want to be in the position that
you're in probably the exact same one
you know getting ready to wind down my
career
and financially stable and like you're
so knowledgeable about it i feel like
there's so much i still need to learn so
i want to be in a position where i know
what i'm doing i can go confidently into
new investments know how to research
them things like that
so really just kind of learning all the
stuff that i don't even know i don't
know yeah yeah next 10 years for you i
want to be a great businesswoman um i
want to be able to also
help the younger generation the younger
girls in the league and i want to be
able to help the young girls who are
kind of green to
not knowing you know because i we didn't
know you know
and be a just a great businesswoman i
would love to be
uh like the lebron james
of you know the wba with everything he's
doing i just want to have my hands in
everything yeah absolutely well i am so
inspired by both of you i'm so happy to
be sitting here with you guys thank you
so much